aujourd'hui dans l'actuelle vous êtes
étudiant et vous recherchez un logement
pour la rentrée prochaine l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin met à
disposition des guides d'information et
tente de rapprocher étudiants et
propriétaires bailleurs un forum dans ce
sens avait lieu ce samedi il y a les
jeux olympiques et les jeux
paralympiques réservée aux athlètes
handicapés et parmi ces athlètes
l'équipe de rugby fauteuil un des
sportifs est venu au technocentre
renault de guyancourt
l'occasion de sensibiliser les
collaborateurs au monde du handicap une
petite entreprise qui résiste bien à la
crise vers déco à magny les hameaux la
société spécialisée dans le paysage voit
son chiffre d'affaires croître et
pourtant elle ne parvient pas à recruter
faute de trouver des postulants la
piscine à vagues de la base de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines vient
d'ouvrir ses portes un premier week-end
morose avec le mauvais temps mais nous
verrons que la base de loisirs regorge
aussi d'autres activités pour vous
occuper
vendredi les résultats du bac sont
tombés et dès le lendemain les nouveaux
lauréats ont pu participer au premier
forum logement de l'université de
versailles saint quentin dans le hall
vauban à guyancourt jeunes et parents
ont rencontré propriétaire et organismes
spécialisés comme le crous l'adil 78
euros s'il ya arpège
ensemble2générations la ville de
versailles où les résidences adel mais
pas facile de trouver un logement pour
ysaline dont ces études dépendent
directement de sa capacité à trouver
rapidement où habitait la semaine
dernière j'avais été à tour car j'avais
postulé allons là bas j'ai été accepté
et j'ai eu un logement et donc si jamais
j'ai pas de logement ici du coup je
pense me réinscrire à tours pour une
licence de roland qu aujourd'hui des
places dans le secteur public sont rares
seuls 16% des dossiers reçus au crous
aboutisse et même si quatre nouvelles
résidences doivent ouvrir à la rentrée
2013 l'université encourage ses
étudiants vers des acteurs privés comme
catherine arthur propriétaires bailleurs
et possède un 18 mètres carrés qu'elle
loue 570 euros par mois et 1 34 m² à 660
euros tout de meubler tu as de
rencontrer quelqu'un qui est très
intéressé et comme j'ai un doute le
chemin qui va certainement se fût se
finir pour la rentrée elle a deux
petites opportunités on a discuté il
vient visiter cet après midi et il ya
des choses que que ça se fasse quoi
aujourd'hui l'université propose 1000
places d'hébergement à ses dix-huit
mille étudiants face à cette pénurie
elle n'hésite pas à prendre les devants
au niveau donc les garanties on a
plusieurs organismes qui s'occupent de
proposer des il est garanti pour les
propriétaires notamment le dispositif de
grl garantie en responsabilité locative
après le fait de louer à des étudiants
c'est en général assez assez sûr parce
que universités aussi derrière et puis
c'est un contrôle des demandes en 200
personnes ont participé à ce premier
forum qui sera renouvelée l'année
prochaine
des salariés qui peuvent tester du sport
en fauteuil pendant leur pause déjeuner
cela s'est passé au technocentre renault
de guyancourt
la marque au losange et soutient depuis
plusieurs années la fédération française
handisport une fédération qui
participera aux jeux paralympiques de
septembre prochain à travers le rugby
fauteuil
qui est né au canada c'est les anciens
hockeyeurs des footballeurs américains
qui devenait tétraplégique ont créé un
peu ce sport est d'ailleurs son nom de
trompe pas ça s'appelait la bo à
l'époque murder ball donc voilà il
fallait du politiquement correct donc ça
s'apprend on va dire glisser gentiment
vers le rugby fauteuil hawks et l'âme et
l'esprit du rugby jusqu'aux les règles
l'arrière cet aspect disons ludique
l'idée bien entendu de sensibiliser au
monde du handicap
françois nana essayer un fauteuil
roulant et sur des obstacles simple il a
pu mesurer la difficulté de l'exercice
trouve que c'est pas facile hein pour
toujours
enfin pour les gens qui sont handicapés
de monter les obstacles et tout ça c'est
pas facile en plus séduit les obstacles
qui paraissent faciles et en fait c'est
double d'efforts en fait l'occasion
aussi pour le constructeur de présenter
ses modèles la dedd à la conduite
renault produit en effet chaque année
1000 véhicules adaptés au transport de
personnes à mobilité réduite un
cinquième accord handicap vient d'être
signé il prévoit l'intégration des
personnes handicapées au sein du secteur
tertiaire et la mise en place d'un
réseau social andy à traîneau pour
échanger sur le sujet
dans doctrine le plus lu une crise au
sein de la zone euro crise une crise
c'est le paradoxe de cette crise la
crise est partout et pourtant elle ne
semble pas touchée vers dés qu une pme
manic oise qui affiche un chiffre
d'affaires de 4 millions 7 mai
l'entreprise rencontre un autre problème
elle peine à trouver de la main d'oeuvre
on n'a pas de problème financier c'est
une honte parce qu'ils se portent bien
on a une progression de chiffre
d'affaires de 5 à 15 % suivant les
années par exemple les derniers en 2011
en a fait 13 % d'augmentation de chiffre
d'affaires l'enseigne créé entretien des
paysages extérieurs et intérieurs pour
les entreprises et les particuliers elle
possède également deux boutiques de
fleurs en ville et un bureau d'études
tous ces employés sont en cdi à titre
d'exemple un ouvrier paysagiste débutant
gagne entre 1400 et 1800 euros avec un
avantage certain la possibilité de
piquer une tête entre deux commandes
mais malgré cela impossible de recruter
met en place des annonces un pôle emploi
les écoles notre site internet mais par
exemple on cherchait un chiffre métreur
pour nous de vie pour construire un peu
d'eau de vie on n'a pas de c maintenant
les formations vont aller au delà de des
postes de jardiniers sur le terrain et
on va trouver plus facilement des postes
d'encadrants que des postes d'ouvriers
sur le terrain le gérant de vrd corp
cherche cinq personnes pour permettre à
son entreprise d'évoluer si aucun
ouvrier paysagiste floor istchee
prometteur au responsable de production
ne vient à lui c'est lui qui ira vers
eux les solutions sont elles sont
multiples c'est soit on essaie de
trouver des gens qui ont peu
d'expérience et on va les former tout au
long de leur carrière
pour les faire évoluer dans le métier
donc ça c'est une solution qu'on est en
train de travailler d'une manière
beaucoup plus forte que les années
précédentes
ou alors retrouver des gens qui veulent
changer de métier et
et donc qu'il soit attiré par le métier
de paysages on a quelques personnes qui
sont en reconversion professionnelle
dans notre entreprise le cas d'olivier b
d'où elle n'est pas isolée les métiers
du paysagiste une profonde mutation et
les demandes en recrutement sont fortes
entre 2008 et 2010 le nombre
d'entreprises paysagère a augmenté de
31%
stéphane salvary est responsable de la
piscine à vagues de la base de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines samedi
dernier c'était l'ouverture officielle
pour la saison d'été 2012 un événement
qualifié de tristounet par stéphane la
piscine n'a en effet réalisé aucune
entrée samedi en cause les orages depuis
des années le sort s'acharne sur les
jours d'ouverture il fait rarement beau
le jour de l'ouverture donc voilà ça
fait cette année encore sa a confirmé
cette règle l'an dernier je pense que ça
a été l'une des saisons les pires sur
les dix dernières années maintenant on
espère que ça va se lever quand même et
qu'on va pas avoir un été aussi
désagréable que l'an dernier dimanche
dernier bassin et cafétéria était désert
décevant surtout lorsqu'on sait que ces
dernières années plus de 2 millions
d'euros ont été investis dans
l'entretien de la piscine à vagues le
mauvais temps impacte également les
autres activités de la base exemple avec
l'association sport events créé en 2011
par des jeunes issus d'une école de
commerce parisienne leur objectif donner
de la visibilité à d'autres associations
à travers des événements sportifs
le week-end dernier un match de sandball
était organisée au profit des sceaux s
enfants mais qu'est ce que le sandball
c'est du handball qui se pratique sur du
sable aujourd'hui malheureusement on n'a
pas énormément de monde parce qu'il fait
pas très beau
comme vous pouvez constater derrière moi
donc du coup on ne rentre un
d'effectivement de jouer nous mêmes en
espérant qu'ils aient des équipes qui
vont arriver tout à l'heure mais c'est
prévu c'est la première fois que
l'association organisait un événement de
ce genre elle en a profité pour
organiser une collecte toujours au
profit des sceaux s enfants
volley rugby handball ou encore cinéma
en plein air les activités ne manquent
pas pendant l'été sur la base de loisirs
à condition que le soleil montre le bout
de son nez grande nouveauté cette année
pour les amateurs de sensations fortes
le wave surfing jusqu'au 23 septembre
nous sommes au théâtre de dix heures je
suis à côtés d'alban ivanoff un comédien
qui vient de chez nous j'ai un peu peur
parce que c'est un improvisateur qui est
très doué et c'est toujours rebondir et
faire des choses un petit peu
surprenante alors je ne vois pas très
bien ce qu'il fait mais il m'a dit qu'il
était très inspiré et huit frères
t'inquiète pas on fait les buy on est là
on est dans les sketchs bikram des
blagues t'inquiète pas on fait notre
petit beurre oui
merci beaucoup de me recevoir et de
m'accorder une petite interview tv fil
78 je trouve ça super cool c'est vrai
que moi aussi je suis du 78 donc par
rapport à mes racines ça me resservent
vachement je me sens soutenu ça me fait
vraiment du bien
voilà tu es venu voir moins de bonnes
choses ça t'a plu j'espère que ça plaira
aux spectateurs téléspectateurs
auditeurs
et tu vois là bas on se retrouve
peut-être juste après pour une interview
si vous le voulez bien
vous l'avez vu alban ivanov est un
comique cet humoriste originaire de
versailles inconnu l'improvisation dès
son plus jeune âge évidemment albon à
fréquenter déclic théâtre où il a
rencontré pappis directeur artistique de
la compagnie trappistes l'homme a aidé
le jeune artiste à construire son
premier one man show passé de
l'improvisation au texte suscite
quelques difficultés puis un jour on
m'avait dit ça très justement il m'avait
dit si tu regardes bien tout les impros
que tu as fait les matchs d'impro que tu
as fait dessus tu as été acteur auteur
et metteur en scène donc c'est juste en
fait de retranscrire tout ce qu'on a
fait à l'oral à l'écrit
tous les mardis alban se produit au
théâtre de dix heures scène parisienne à
la recherche de jeunes talents son
premier spectacle se situe à mi chemin
entre stand-up et interprétation de
personnages alban us d'un franc parler
et ne craint pas les critiques ces
propos crus il les assume à l'image de
l'acteur porno qui s'adresse à andré un
ami très intime mais c'est sûr c'est pas
évident a tourné trois films une journée
oui c'est dur quoi je te dis je parlais
avec ambri des génies et ont pris qu'ils
en oublient qu'ils ont vraiment habile
pauvres car
si je vois que ça dérange quelqu'un ou
ou que ça le fait réagir ben c'est
pareil c'est pour montrer une certaine
manière que je suis conscient de 2,2 ce
que je fais voilà j'assume j'assume
parmi les personnages d'albon certains
reconnaîtront vénère un rappeur à la
rime acerbe née au comedy club
albon reviendra au théâtre de dix heures
dès le mois de septembre en attendant
vous pourrez retrouver les mardis 17 et
24 juillet julie galibert une autre
artiste liés à des kicks théâtre